la visita del ministro de relaciones
exteriores japonés yoshimasa en suelo
chino significó el primer viaje de un
diplomático de alto nivel a China en más
de tres años se da en un momento en el
que las tensiones regionales van en
aumento el canciller nipón se reunió con
el Primer Ministro lichian y con el
principal diplomático One shee
previamente también lo hizo con su
homólogo King kongó el valor simbólico
para entablar buenas relaciones
bilaterales quiero trabajar con ustedes
con base en el importante consenso
alcanzado por los líderes de los dos
países fortalecer los intercambios
promover las relaciones bilaterales
eliminar la injerencia y superar las
dificultades para avanzar en los
cónclaves toque insistió en la necesidad
de una estabilidad en el estrecho de
Taiwán y expuso a las preocupaciones por
las actividades militares en los mares
de China meridional y oriental en tanto
que también se refirió a la situación
del ciudadano japonés detenido por
visión por motivos desconocidos Beijing
dijo que será tratado Según la ley
hice una protesta contra el nuevo caso
reciente detención de un japonés en
Beijing y hasta que nuestra posición al
respecto incluso para la liberación
anticipada de este ciudadano
los arrestos por parte de autoridades
chinas japoneses no son una novedad al
menos 16 ciudadanos japoneses fueron
detenidos por accidente asiático por
sospecha de actividades de espionaje de